This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6 Minute English.
From BBC Learning English.
Hello and welcome to 6 Minute English. I'm Catherine.
And hello, I'm Rob.
Now Rob, do you ever buy things at a charity shop?
Yes, I do. They are a great place to pick up a bargain.
And I also donate items to charity shops too.
And a charity shop, by the way, is a shop where people
take their unwanted items and then the shop sells them
and makes money and the money goes to charity.
Exactly, that's good to hear Rob because donating,
that's giving money or goods to an organisation,
helps charities raise money.
And you might be interested to know that dressing up
in second-hand clothes is back in fashion.
Well, sort of.
And that's what we're discussing today.
Is looking like you're dressing in charity shop clothes
a new fashion statement?
It should be interesting, but first Catherine,
aren't you going to set me a question to answer?
And not a second-hand one, please.
It's a brand new question today, Rob.
For you and the listeners at home,
do you know when the first official charity shop opened its doors
in the UK?
Was it in A1928, B1948 or C1948?
I'll go for 1948.
OK, and we'll find out the answer later.
But now back to our discussion about charity shops and fashion.
And there's a new look-in-town
which some people are calling Scumbro.
Scumbro combines the word scummy,
which means dirty and messy,
with the word bro,
which is an informal way of referring to a boy or a man.
So Scumbro is a fashion for men,
but women can't adopt it too.
It's a bit of insulting name,
and here's the odd thing about this new fashion style.
Being Scumbro is about buying expensive designer brands
that look like they're from a charity shop, very odd.
Well, it's something Amber Graffland knows about.
She's the fashion and beauty director
for the Daily Mirror newspaper,
and she's been telling BBC Radio 4's
you and yours programme all about it.
So how did this trend start?
Well, I think the name came from a vanity fair article,
and I think Justin Bieber,
the likes of Jonah Hill, to thank for this look.
Pete Davidson, who's actually the fiance of Ariana Grande,
he's definitely one of the founding fathers of Scumbro.
And I think like most of these trends,
they're started by celebrities,
and then they, I mean, look, it's been picked up by everybody
by the sounds of them.
Okay, so the fashion magazine vanity fair invented the name,
but the trend has spread because celebrities
have been dressing in this style.
Yes, and Amber mentioned a number of celebrities
who are the founding fathers of the trend.
That's a term used to describe people
who start an idea or an organisation.
Yes, the trend has been picked up or copied by people
who you might describe as fashion victims,
people who have to follow the latest fashion trends.
Well, Rob, I'm no fashion victim,
but I say maybe one day I might want to look Scumbro,
or maybe Scumsis.
So how exactly should I dress?
Okay, well, let's hear from Amber Graffland again.
How does she describe the characteristics of this fashion trend?
It's all about Rayne's oversized clothes that are overpriced,
and I think it's not just about looking like you've rummaged
in a teenager's dressing up box.
These are very, very expensive items.
You mentioned the label's Prada Fasachi,
Gucci Supreme.
While it's basically about looking simultaneously
like you've made no effort,
but the underlying thing is that you do need to see
that the effort has gone in there.
Well, this fashion trend does involve a lot of effort.
It's not just about looking messy,
like you've rummaged in a teenager's dressing up box.
rummaging is when you search for something that's mixed up
with lots of other things.
No, don't be rummaging.
The trick seems to be to look like you've not made any effort,
but at the same time, you're showing that you have made an effort,
and that's the meaning of the word simultaneously,
doing one thing at the same time as another thing.
And I guess by showing you've made an effort,
you wear designer labels, showing you've paid lots of money.
The issue here is clothes from charity shops
are supposed to be cheap.
Some people even buy these clothes
because it's all they can afford.
But the irony here is some people are choosing
to pay lots and lots of money
to look like they're wearing second-hand clothes.
And the charity shops aren't making any money from it.
Well, if you're a fashion victim,
it's something you have to do.
And there's one thing I have to do now,
and that's give you the answer to today's quiz question.
So I asked you earlier,
when the first official charity shop opened its doors in the UK.
And I said, 1948.
And you are correct this week, Rob Weldon.
The very first shop run by the charity Oxfam
opened its doors in Oxford in 1948
as a direct result of an appeal launched
to help post-war Greece.
Very interesting.
Right, well, let's remind ourselves
of some of today's vocabulary,
starting with the word donating,
which means giving goods or money
to an organisation or charity.
Then we mentioned Founding Fathers,
a term used to describe people who start an idea
or an organisation.
We also mentioned that Catherine was no fashion victim,
a person who has to follow the latest fashion trends.
Rummaging was a word that described searching for something
that's mixed up with lots of other things.
And then we had simultaneously,
which means doing one thing at the same time
as doing something else.
Well, you can simultaneously listen to this programme
and look at our website, if you like.
The web address is bbclearningenglish.com.
But that's all we have time for now.
Join us again next time.
Goodbye. Bye-bye.